the Dark Souls 3 saga is coming to a  close and we just got a glimpse of the  final expansion the ring city comes with  the usual dose of new weapons armor and  magic and publisher Namco Bandai says  it's full of quote new Horrors to  overcome the official description reads  this new adventure has players chasing  after the slave night jail to the  literal end of the world as he searches  for the dark soul of humanity at the  close of the age of fire as the world  ends in all lands converge upon  themselves a lone adventurer descends  into the madness of the earth and  uncovers the secrets of the past the  ring city comes to ps4 xbox one and pc  on march 28 it's included with Dark  Souls 3 season pass or you can grab it  for 15 bucks by itself tune in the game  spot for more info as the date grows  closer and to keep up with all the Dark  Souls news be sure to hit that subscribe  button  you